this morning a high-ranking Iranian
military official says Iran will punish
Americans wherever they are in reach US
military units are on high alert to
protect some American embassies in
Africa and the Middle East security
alerts are issued for US embassies in
Bahrain Kuwait and Nigeria Kenneth Craig
is here with more on the security
measures taking place in this country
Kenneth good morning well good morning
to you Dana law enforcement agencies
around the nation are taking this as a
serious threat they're deploying
additional patrols and urging civilians
to be vigilant at the nation's capitol
the Secret Service stands heavily armed
with long guns in a statement Friday
DHS acting secretary Chad Wolfe said the
Department of Homeland Security is
assessing potential new threats against
the US and that the department stands
ready we are doing this morning with a
reality we've not faced previously New
York City Mayor Bill de Blasio announced
heightened police presence around the
city additional officers have already
been deployed at key landmarks like the
UN building and the NYPD is always ready
to do things that will disrupt terror
other cities around the nation like
Philadelphia are following suit Sanders
got a touchdown Lincoln Financial Field
will see increased security measures for
the Philadelphia Eagles playoff game on
Sunday but police at Los Angeles
International Airport say they have not
made any adjustments to security
protocols due to the lack of a credible
threat Transportation Security and
counterterrorism expert Errol suburbs US
officials believe in recent years
Iranian backed hackers have targeted US
infrastructure for cyberattacks like the
one that breached the computers
controlling this dam just north of New
York City Michael Morell former acting
director of the CIA says Iran could take
any number of actions including
assassination they will choose a time
and they will choose a place to conduct
a terrorist attack
against a senior American official might
be two months from now it might be a
year from now but they will exact their
revenge Anne Morel went on to say that
major cities like New York City remain
at the top of the list for a potential
terror attack Jeff okay thank you very
much
you